I have to chuckle a little bit when I'm
approached by anybody but in particular
journalists and say our scientists
worried that the public is in denial of
science or is cherry-picking and I
chuckle not because it's funny but
because they're coming to me as a
scientist when they should be going to
everyone everyone should be concerned by
this not just scientists that scientists
could just continue as they're doing you
might withdraw funding but then there
isn't a science done okay you are
transforming your civilization if you
choose to either stand in denial of
science or withdraw science funding from
those who are actually doing the
research everything we care deeply about
that defines modern civilization pivots
on innovations in science technology
engineering and the math that is the
foundational language for at all
everything transportation your health
your communication through smartphones
that talk to GPS satellites to find out
where grandma is okay what to make a
left turn to find her address or to the
nearest Starbucks whatever is your need
whatever is your want the emergent
innovations in science and technology
are not only enabling it they are
creating for you solutions to two
challenges you always lived with but
never thought that they could be solved
the message is clear if you do not
understand what science is and how and
why it works by the way I'm not even
blaming you I look back as an educator I
look back to K through 12
kindergarten through twelfth grade and I
say there's something missing there if
you as a as an educated adult can say
this is what the scientists agree to but
I don't agree with them if that sentence
even comes out of your mouth it's like
oh my gosh okay well we live in a free
country you can say and think what you
want I'm not even going to stop you but
if you rise to power and have influence
over legislation and that legislation
references what you think science is but
it's not that is that is a recipe for
the unraveling of an informed democracy
and so I'm not going to blame you it's
not your fault I'm an educator let's go
back to K through 12 somewhere in there
while you're learning about reading
writing and arithmetic and while you
have a class in earth science and
biology and chemistry
maybe physics some way in there there
needs to be a class possibly taught
every year on what it is to analyze
knowledge information how to process
facts how to turn how to turn data into
information and information into
knowledge and how to turn knowledge into
wisdom because it is wisdom that you
need to invoke when you're a leader you
need insight into not only what is going
on but what will then happen in the
future as a consequence of your
decisions
you know who had all of that Abraham
Lincoln we think of him we remember him
you know a civil war and slavery two top
categories that he's justifiably
remembered for you know why I also
remember him in 1863 you know what he
did by the way that year he had plenty
of other things any other priorities in
his life 1863 the middle of the Civil
War Gettysburg Address that same year he
signed into law
the National Academy of Sciences who
were charged with advising the executive
and the legislative branch of always
that science needs to be recognized as a
fundamental part of what will assure the
future health wealth and security of the
nation by the way Abe Lincoln was a
Republican president greatly valuing
what science is going to tell him this
puts into motion a valuation of academic
science that would boost the United
States from a backwoods country into the
world's leading economic force and he
had the wisdom the insight the knowledge
he knew how to think about that problem
today you have partisanship over what is
science again people somehow don't
understand what science is and how and
why it works that has to be a course in
the curriculum k12 right through college
because everyone in Congress went to
college and so if you come out of
college and don't know this we need some
of that in college as well now the
partisanship you hear liberals claiming
the science high ground accusing
right-leaning people of science denial
generally in reference to climate change
data and as well but less frequently
teaching evolution in the biology
classroom people want to teach biblical
creation so this high ground is not as
high a ground as the liberal community
would want to claim because there's a
portfolio of things
that for you to think that way will
require that you reject some mainstream
science and in that portfolio you find
people who lean left if you are all in
for for alternative medicine and if
you're anti GMO is your anti vex you are
in denial of mainstream science period
so we have these two political ends of
the spectrum
each accusing the other of whatever and
I'm saying science has no political
party it is true when you establish an
objective truth with the methods and
tools of science it is true no matter
what political party you are what your
pullet what your philosophies are what
religion you belong to what country
you're born in that's why it's science
it may be unique among human enterprises
that it transcends all of this now what
we need to do is recognize what science
is how and why it works and what are the
objectively established scientific
truths then have the political
conversation then oh do you put in
carbon tax or tariffs on solar panels
should you invest in this and this
industry should you subsidize it should
you
those have political solutions my jaw
drops open every time I see people
having a political conversation arguing
about a scientific truth that we're
wasting time people because nature is
the ultimate judge jury and executioner
and the whole point of science is to
find out what nature is how it works
how we can best use our knowledge of
nature in the service of our needs and
the needs of others across the world so
yeah this keeps up the Unites States
will just fade
and the rest of the world that
understands how to invoke scientific
insight and knowledge will rise up and
will just become irrelevant on the world
stage by the way when you innovate your
jobs don't go overseas because you are
innovating here and this is where the
intellectual capital for that is located
that's how that works if you're going to
complain about trade imbalances it's
because you're doing what everybody else
is doing and now you want to protect
your jobs by putting tariffs on other
people so that you can buy our own
products but if you innovate you are
making products that no one else knows
how to make yet so the whole concept of
tariffs and this this is a that's what
you do when you're not leading it's you
you have those conversations when you're
the same as everybody and then you go
into a protectionist mode and one one
last point about immigrants on average
since 1900 about 1 in 10 Americans was
born in another country so 10 percent
immigrants average it's fluctuated from
like 5% to 14% but since 1900 averages
about one in ten the Nobel Prizes have
been given since 1900 let's ask the
question what percent of American Nobel
Prizes in the sciences were won by
immigrants one third of all Nobel Prizes
given to Americans since Nobel Prizes
began have gone to immigrants they are
three times a factor of three more
represented in scientific scholarship as
represented by the Nobel Prize than they
are even in the population how does this
happen
we were leading the world in science
technology engineering and math so
they're the most brilliant minds around
the world we're attracted to us
contributing to who and what America
became as we begin to fade that all goes
away the brilliant minds are attracted
elsewhere and America fades it's not a
cliff face it's just a slope maybe so
gradually you're not even thinking about
it
and one day we wake up then we start
running behind other countries saying
can we join in tell us how you did it
that's actually not the America I grew
up in
[Music]